[Música]
en el corazón del estado de bahía santo
amaro es una pequeña ciudad en la que el
tiempo parece haberse detenido
detrás de estas fachadas coloniales una
tragedia industrial y medioambiental
condenó a cientos de hombres y mujeres a
una muerte silenciosa se trataría de una
de las ciudades más contaminadas con
plomo en el mundo todo empezó en 1960
cuando se instaló una fundición
yo vivía en esa casa miren
cuando la fábrica operaba en esta calle
los vehículos circulaban con las luces
encendidas porque nadie podía verse
debido a la humareda que salía de la
chimenea
a dyson trabajo durante tan solo seis
meses en la fábrica justo antes de su
cierre en 1993 hoy en día es quien
lidera la lucha de las víctimas de la
contaminación por metales pesados estas
fábricas como la bomba de hiroshima como
una explosión que sigue haciendo daños y
sigue matando a la gente de a poco
la fábrica originalmente una filial del
grupo francés pena joya empleo en total
a unas 3000 personas durante 33 años
1114 habría muerto por causas derivadas
de la contaminación
a daily son reúne a los antiguos
trabajadores que aún viven en el local
de la asociación de las víctimas con el
fin de actualizarlos sobre los procesos
judiciales iniciados
todo el mundo cuenta su historia de
sufrimiento porque la mía
porque la mía no la escondo todos estos
antiguos trabajadores sufren de secuelas
irremediables las micro partículas de
plomo que inhalaban durante todo el día
afectaron poco a poco todos sus órganos
a lois yo trabajaba muy cerca del horno
en el que se fundía el plomo
y hoy os estructura
hoy en día sufro de vértigo de dolores
en todo el cuerpo
quien haya trabajado en la fábrica
tiene secuelas
numerosos de estos antiguos trabajadores
ya no cuentan con la capacidad física
para trabajar un poco más de 400 de
ellos obtuvieron indemnizaciones ante la
justicia distinga
siete mil euros
manuel batista
mil euros mil euros
en situación de precariedad muchos
aceptaron montos irrisorios
cuando fui al tribunal la jueza me
preguntó si aceptaba la suma de 80 euros
yo dije que mejor que nada que 80 euros
es menos de lo que gasta comprando mis
medicamentos
la contaminación con plomo genera
patologías raras que necesitan
especialistas cuyos honorarios no están
al alcance de la mayoría de los
extrabajadores entonces fallecen de a
poco a dyson insiste en presentarnos
ayer matic
buena idea
hola cómo estás
más o menos en todos los órganos están
afectados en la medida en que no recibe
ninguna ayuda es su hermana quien se
ocupa de él si hubiese recibido algo un
poco de dinero me cuidaría mejor porque
podría consultar a un médico
todos sus dedos
quiero un poco
los obreros como jerome a ti no son las
únicas víctimas como ignoraba los
riesgos en los años 80 la alcaldía usó
desechos de plomo ofrecidos por la
fábrica para revestir las calles de la
ciudad toda la población de santo amaro
fue expuesta hay una tasa elevada de
cáncer el abogado de la asociación de
las víctimas también mencionan numerosos
casos de malformaciones congénitas con
la santa fe a tres fetos de niños que
nacieron completamente formados con las
vísceras afuera para probar ante la
justicia la relación causa-efecto entre
exposición a los metales pesados y todas
estas patologías se necesitan costosos
exámenes óseos y el estado debería
asumir el costo y nunca lo hizo
aprovechándose de ello las empresas que
causaron los daños
reclaman pruebas es derecho lo exige no
hace falta esa prueba técnica la
sociedad minera francesa pena joya
propietario inicial de la fábrica fue
reestructurada numerosas veces lo que
complicó la búsqueda de justicia según
este abogado se comprometió a
respetarlas
y las reglas del país y no lo hizo se
fue sin dejar representantes entonces
seguimos tratando de hacer responder a
peñarroya a través de las sociedades que
la reemplazaron metal europa recicla c's
y otras empresas un verdadero
rompecabezas para las víctimas la
sociedad jazzy clics no respondió a
nuestros llamados y nuestros correos
pero dyson se niega a bajar los brazos
defendió incluso la causa de los
contaminados ante el ex presidente lula
antiguo obrero metalúrgico que le pedí
que una fundación de ayuda a las
víctimas fuese creada fue en 2008 y nada
ha cambiado
la fábrica cerró dejando atrás ella 500
mil toneladas de desechos industriales
que siguen contaminando tanto el suelo
como el río cercano
paulo sergio pesca aquí desde su
infancia como en sus dos hijos su tasa
de plomo en la sangre es anormalmente
elevada y los moluscos absorben el plomo
si pescamos aquí no conseguimos nada hay
que ir más lejos hacia el mar de lo
contrario la gente dice la pesca se
acerca a la fábrica está contaminado
resignado paulo sergio no ve solución
distinta a la reconstrucción de la
ciudad en otro lugar 60 años después de
la instalación de la fábrica el plomo
sigue envenenando el río sube y los
responsables siguen sin castigo